[Music]
so
i want us to be lifting ourselves up
[Applause]
and that's what i will do if i'm so
honored as to be
your president
[Music]
she is the most experienced candidate
ever
first female president of america thank
you
woman with a global profile
[Applause]
hillary clinton has been the most famous
woman in the world
for a long time now and with the chance
of making american history
people are ready to see a woman
lead the nation
[Music]
the presidency should be hillary
clinton's destiny
but instead of a coronation it's become
a slog
with familiar scandal and new
controversies
she's somebody who doesn't think the
rules apply to her
and has consistently felt she doesn't
need to shoot straight with the american
people
once american royalty now one of the
most
polarizing candidates in history she's
quite unpopular
people don't like her so what is the
problem
with hillary clinton
[Music]
ready to win this election
[Music]
hillary clinton's journey towards the
presidency has had more twists and turns
than most
[Music]
i followed this american icon along that
route
to find out who she really is and
whether she can
secure the most powerful job in the
world
[Music]
she was first lady to one of america's
most charismatic
and perhaps flawed presidents a husband
who turned their marriage into a soap
opera for the world
[Music]
those white house years though became
the foundation for what came next
in her own political career
[Applause]
in 2016 the candidate who so many
americans
just don't like
thank you
[Music]
what do you think of hillary clinton oh
my
uh i'll just say i'm not voting for her
thank you okay
is there anything in particular that you
don't like about her uh pretty much
everything
what do you think of hillary clinton i
think she's terrible i think she should
be in prison
not a fan then not a fan if you have to
think of one word that some sums are up
in your mind what would it be
um let's see i would probably say
she is a typical politician
[Music]
by default i like her
she's not my perfect candidate but i
would vote for her over trump
i don't like her i'm upset about her but
i'm unfortunately going to have to vote
for her
not a fan not a fan at all i think she's
distrustful
deceitful she would make a horrible
president
well i may not be the youngest candidate
in this race
but i will be the youngest
woman president in the history of the
united states
and one additional advantage you won't
see
my hair turn white in the white house
i've been coloring it
for years
the striking thing to me about covering
hillary clinton has always been
that there are so many people who go to
see her
and aren't enthusiastic about her you
have a crowd of thousands of people
who've come out to cheer hillary clinton
on the day she announces her candidacy
and you wait into the crowd
and half of them turn out to be sort of
well i'm a democrat
she's okay i guess or i have serious
issues with her but she's famous so i
came out to see her
they're just there are people who are
enthusiastic about hillary clinton
but there are also a lot of people who
are voting for her out of a sense of
duty
or sort of partisan obligation
for all those doubts 15 million
americans did vote for hillary clinton
in the primaries
millions more than for any other
candidate she does have a large
dedicated and vocal following
[Applause]
[Music]
they were queuing outside west los
angeles college before eight o'clock in
the morning
this is what american politics looks
like today
passion and engagement more like what
you see at a sports event
the result matters
[Music]
in the queue three generations of the
hooton family
[Music]
if all goes well i will have the great
honor
to be the democratic nominee
for president thank you all so much god
bless you
[Applause]
[Music]
what does it feel like to be there stood
for maybe
a straight four or five hours
we didn't know if we would be even close
enough to see her
or if we would be able to get inside we
just thought we'll wait
we might be way in the back who knows
and then we came in we were right in the
front
i was gonna try to get a picture and
then josie was like give him the camera
that was crazy huh yeah and then when we
were taking a selfie with
hillary clinton and then uh also
we got to shake her hand that it just
felt like
a dream and didn't feel like it actually
was happening
she looked to you right in the eyes and
she said thank you thank you
yeah that was pretty cool
[Music]
the issues that are most important to me
are the ones
that are inclusive of the most people
and that's what we teach our kids at
home and that's what i like to hear from
her
is what she's going to do to represent
a lot of different groups especially
marginalized groups that deserve a voice
and ideally that's what a president
should do she's so ready for it but it's
and it's also it's not just about
uh us here in the u.s or here in
california
i think that and she demonstrated this
as secretary of state like she's got a
vision
for the whole world it's been a long
struggle for her and she's had to climb
up hill against a lot of uh a lot of uh
prejudice about women um that's not why
hillary clinton should be president
hillary clinton
should be president because she's the
smartest person running and she was the
smartest person running when there were
20 candidates and she's the most capable
and most experienced person running
but i do think milestones like that make
a difference
she's not judged as a conventional
politician there have been
for many years conversations at dinner
tables all
over the world every night by the
hundreds of thousands about who is this
person and analyzing her character
and looking at her in in simplistic
terms
uh that you ordinarily apply to movie
stars lives
[Music]
yet all those years playing the
political game it seems guaranteed
nothing
as we race towards that ultimate
popularity contest
[Music]
at realclearpolitics we track all the
major polls
and we compute a lot of averages to try
to get a sense of where the public is
in general
what's happened from last summer through
to now
before she was officially running for
president oftentimes her favorable
unfavorable
rating was about plus eight so it would
be something like
52 percent of the country of user
favorably 44
unfavorably something along those lines
something pretty good
for a political figure and then once the
primary started heating up people
started thinking of her politically
again
it was a pretty drastic drop in
favorability and pretty drastic
increase in unfavorability
she's not particularly popular as
normal presidential nominees go in fact
i think she's the second most unpopular
presidential nominee
in i want to say the history of polling
but
the most unpopular is donald trump so
she still has a definite advantage there
ladies and gentlemen the next president
of the united states mr donald j
trump 2016 has become about
who americans dislike least
she's a world-class liar just look at
her pathetic email server statements
she believes she's entitled to the
office her campaign
slogan is i'm with her you know what my
response is to that
i'm with you the american people
i want you to listen to me i'm going to
say this again
i did not have sexual relations with
that woman
miss lewinsky i never told anybody to
lie
not a single time never these
allegations
are false and i need to go back to work
for the american people thank you
yes i was bill clinton's lover for 12
years
and for the past two years i have lied
to the press about a relationship to
protect him
the truth is i loved him
i never asked anybody to do anything but
tell the truth bill and i have been
accused
of everything including murder abc news
reported someone else at the white house
may have caught president clinton
and lewinsky in an intimate moment
i owe it to the american people to put
it in a little box
and keep working for them day after day
i've seen his determination his
unrelenting determination
the allegations are false
be patient take a deep breath and the
truth will come out
i'm not sitting here as some little
woman standing by my man like tammy
wyant
i love him and i respect him it's almost
impossible to prove your innocence
and he would try to pay me a great deal
of attention with her there
everybody says to me how can you be so
calm or how can you just
you know look like you're not upset and
i guess i've just been through it so
many times
instead of speaking out she stood
smiling at her husband's side
from my perspective this is part of the
continuing
political campaign against my husband
there's going to be a war
a war between whom between the friends
of the president and the independent
council that's exactly who it's between
in between these scuzzy slimy tactics of
of
wiring people up some folks are going to
have a lot to answer for
you know it made a lot of people mad
when i got elected president the
president's conduct was deplorable
and being he hereby is acquitted of the
charge congress is going to impeach the
president the
presumption of innocence belongs to the
president
i want to say again to the american
people
indeed i did have a relationship with
miss lewinsky that was not
appropriate in fact it was wrong
it constituted a critical lapse in
judgment and a personal failure on my
part
for which i am solely and completely
responsible
i misled people even my wife
in this issue her his cheating heart
we found we unveiled paula corbin jones
paula corbin jones instituted a sex
sexual abuse case against bill clinton
he lied about that
in that case and he got himself
impeached it wouldn't have happened it
hadn't been in the american spectator
we tripped across the most interesting
story of the 1990s
bill clinton's ongoing excess
and hillary's ongoing enabling
of bill's excessive behavior with women
and of course
this was a more penetrating piece than
anything woodward and bernstein did
i mean this really caught him you know
seducing woman after woman after woman
on parking lots and
in the governor's mansion and places
like that
because the clintons have been
really in the crosshairs of the cultural
wars of this country for so long
the quote vast right-wing conspiracy end
quote
it's kind of real we actually published
a story in the american spectator
i think was 96 about how bill
cheated his golf game he was caught
cheating at golf by one of our reporters
i mean it was a funny story but it was
it was a part of this
great pageant of lies that they've been
putting together since uh 1992.
she as you know has described all of all
of what you write all of
what a lot of people write is this this
conspiracy against this vast right-wing
conspiracy
what do you say to people who say that
in her defense well i'd say
how would we be managed to provide
material
new material year after year after year
if she weren't crooked i mean this
when she was made secretary of state
she was in a perfect position to commit
no more blunders
no more scandals and what did she do
she committed blunder after blunder
scandal after scandal
[Music]
those four years as america's top
diplomat gave her enemies plenty of
ammunition
accused of failing the americans who
died in benghazi
but cleared of blame wow
unconfirmed reports about gaddafi being
captured my husband is not the secretary
of state i am
so you ask my opinion i will tell you my
opinion i'm not going to
be channeling my husband
it is another state department scandal
that haunts her
when hillary clinton became secretary of
state rather than use
the government provided state department
email system
she used her own email and she stored
those emails on a private server
in her home that she had set up for that
purpose on that private system she also
distributed or received a lot of
information
that was technically classified and
should not have been
exposed to the public internet
[Music]
110 emails in 52 email chains
contain classified information i did not
email any classified material
to anyone on my email there is no
classified material eight of those
chains
contained information that was top
secret i opted for convenience to use my
personal email account
which was allowed by the state
department the security culture of the
state department
was generally lacking i thought it would
be easier
to carry just one device for my work and
for my personal emails
instead of two none of these emails
should have been on any kind of
unclassified system
looking back uh it would have been
probably
uh you know smarter to have used two
devices
it is possible that hostile actors
gained access
to secretary clinton's personal email
account in retrospect this didn't turn
out to be convenient at all
we cannot find a case that would support
bringing criminal charges on these facts
well i'm sorry you're the secretary of
state and under law your official
communications are the property of the
american people not your own personal
preserve
her campaign is a very difficult time
dealing with it i mean when they asked
to explain it
they basically say uh she's been under
the gun
uh for so long under attack from
republicans for so long that she sort of
developed a paranoia
and maybe she goes overboard with it
sometimes but she has a justified reason
to be nervous right to be afraid
playing about two is
that somebody throwing something at me
is that part of cirque du soleil
ironically for somebody who has met you
know a trust problem
she's actually i think the most
trustworthy person we've seen in a very
long time running for president
i think part of her problem is she knows
that some of the things without nuance
aren't entirely true
and that's a problem for her because she
has a very high standard of truth
you know it's easy to tear down it's
hard to build up
it's easy to insult it's easy
to criticize why on earth make that
decision
when she must have known the risks that
came along with that
it's clearly something
that was done to evade
the requirements of
the freedom of information acts who uses
the freedom of information act
well yes political enemies do but also
the press it's a basic tool
of of of the press hillary hates
the press that doesn't mean that you can
set up your own server in your basement
and say well i'm not subject to the
subpoenas
[Music]
it's especially problematic for her
because it's fresh
a lot of the baggage of hillary
clinton's political life comes
from her husband's administration and
his ancient history to a lot of voters
older voters feel like they've heard it
before younger voters feel like it was
something they learned in history class
so to have this scandal that is fresh
and that is complicated
so without knowing the details a lot of
people can just look at it
and see it as a dark cloud hanging over
her campaign
you know you got to make split decisions
that's what leadership
is all about this kind of secrecy
uh is a clinton hallmark it's a clinton
sort of political hallmark and it makes
people very very nervous
secrecy issue is a problem the
trustworthy issue is a problem what the
email is a problem
i think there's a perception that
wherever the clintons go
there's a mess it's kind of astonishing
and it can come back and bite you in the
ass
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
the excitement the enthusiasm the sense
of political momentum
all for a democrat who wasn't hillary
clinton
when you stand in the crowd at a bernie
sanders rally
you feel what he's tapped into the
discontent with politicians
the sense that a lot of people are being
left behind
like donald trump bernie got that
hillary clinton
didn't if you want a candidate
who's going to help create a government
which works for all
of us and not just the one percent
we need your help i have been on the
road with
bernie supporters and hillary supporters
and a lot of bernie supporters are still
not ready to embrace hillary clinton's
democratic nominee a lot of people i
talk to were talking about voting for a
third party candidate
or not voting at all so i think there's
a lot of democrats who still have a lot
of problems with her
i think she means well but i honestly
think that
money has talked to her more i think
that there are big corporations that are
guiding her a lot and i i
don't think i can trust her what do you
think about hillary clinton
next question ultimately when push comes
to shove i may
vote hillary just because i do not want
donald trump in office
trump is unamerican to me he should
be deported between clinton and him
i think it's quite a fine line and i
just see it as hey if it's gonna go to
let's just go there let's do it fast
quick
and something will rise out of the ashes
so the revolution would come with donald
trump yes it would
i mean it's either it's slow death or
quick death between the two
[Music]
as a clinton she's always been able to
count on the african-american vote
even that this time has been weakened by
the doubts about her
the message is never hillary no one
who's burning or busts
will ever vote for hillary clinton and
that definitely includes me
people feel that they're gonna have to
hold their nose while they cast their
vote
i think that's a ridiculous idea
what hillary is doing right now for
black people
is she's making more money and making
ways for you for college and funds
you believe that i believe that there's
a part of me
in my conscience that would never allow
me
to vote for her hillary knows more about
foreign policy
okay all right okay so let's go i mean
now when it comes to like america
he does well i mean uh free health care
college tuition all that kind of stuff
is great but i got to think about the
bigger picture yeah
how is she the best candidate for the
world she's the best i mean right now
she is
i would never vote for hillary clinton
well i have to look and i know 10
times he doesn't get in if he doesn't
get a general election but listen and
then
if adolf hitler ran as a democrat are
you going to vote for him because he's a
democrat
that's why we don't do that you are one
young
black man in america who needs to make
the best decision
based on the best person available
thank you one more convert baby
love you mr sanders god bless you see
you
bye bye bye here's what's going to
happen with bernie's voters
there's going to be about 20 to vote for
trump young people are going to vote for
hillary clinton
young people are not sort of the cranky
i hate everybody
type of people they're this this new
generation is in general
extremely pragmatic much more so than we
are they have our same ideals as
those of us the baby boomers these are
our children
[Music]
what they call america's rust belt
places like
rural kentucky have also traditionally
been democrat territory
this time bypassed by the economic
recovery
some are looking elsewhere for their
[Music]
savior
[Music]
the political landscape of america has
shifted and a candidate who's been a
fixture of american life for so long
is finding a country that's changing
well
that's the america i want to build for
the 21st century will you help
[Applause]
will you help for 70 more days
will you help for four more years there
were just
thousands of people it was a sweltering
day i mean
it was hot we haven't had
too many presidents that that have come
to ashland you know bill clinton was
was very popular at that time the
economy was was so much better
thank you and god bless you hang in
there let's go
[Music]
[Music]
my dad was a coal miner and we spent
many you know a lot of time just really
struggling because he would get laid off
or they would go on strike to fight the
the contract to try to get their
benefits so the fact is
coal mining has never been an easy
or dependable living really it's just
you know when things are good things are
good and then
they're quite quite the opposite you
know extreme when they're bads
the coal industry has kind of been on a
decline and
you know in particular during the obama
administration coal's been on a serious
decline
so we are the trickle-down part of of
what's happened with coal
so kids coming out of high school you
know and going to college
you know so many of them don't come back
and and that's kind of sad
we're going to put a lot of coal miners
and coal companies
out of business i just want to know how
you can say
you're going to put a lot of coal miners
out of out of jobs
and then come in here and tell us how
you're going to be our friend
because those people out there don't see
you as a friend
her stance on coal has is pretty
much out there and i'm not sure people
around here appreciate that
too much so not as popular
as as president clinton was for sure
for all the scandal from his presidency
bill clinton is hugely popular
he's also a high profile reminder of
what his wife
is not i do not believe in my lifetime
anybody has run for this job at a moment
of great importance
who was better qualified by knowledge
experience
and temperament to do what needs to be
done now
to restore prosperity to deal with these
human issues
to make us as safe as possible thank you
very much and god bless you
hillary clinton has the tremendous
misfortune to be intimately connected to
two of the most
charismatic american politicians of the
previous century
bill clinton is sort of a freak of
nature in his ability to connect with
people he has this
uncanny ability to
make friends in whatever room he goes
into and make people feel
that they are personally connected to
him as soon as he opens his mouth
that's a very rare trait and it's
certainly not one that hillary clinton
shares
i have won my last campaign
and i couldn't be prouder of the things
we've done together but i'm ready to
pass the baton
and i know that hillary clinton is going
to take it
and i know she can run that race the
race to create
good jobs and better schools and safer
streets
and a safer world and that's why i'm
fired up and that's why i'm ready to go
and that's why i'm with her and that's
why i need you to work
just as hard to make sure that hillary
rodham clinton is the next president of
the united states of america
god bless him
[Applause]
in a world in which we sort of do the do
the the metric against
obama uh an order so amazing that he was
you know won the nobel peace prize
just for being elected president right
she's not at that level
she's not gonna come in and wow a room
she doesn't have the gift of woo
she's like a woo everyone towards her
she's not bill clinton
is she not personable she says things
that come across as tone deaf
this is her life story in terms of
likability
it was said about george w bush
that he was the president that you'd
want to have a beer with
he also made a lot of political
decisions
that hurt a lot of people in a lot of
places
even though she can't sort of stand
there on stage and give a
bill clinton-style stem winder she's not
be able to sort of pull that off yet
uh she has enough political skill that
she can really
chop somebody up on the debate stage
you'd better be prepared with all the
facts when you
make your case to hillary clinton or
you're going to be
sent packing quickly she's not going to
change everyone knows what to expect
she's been really clear about how she
wants to do things and
what she's done and i take comfort in
that
and i think she'll do it well
thank you thank you thank you all very
much
thank you very much
hillary clinton may be the most corrupt
person
ever to seek the presidency of the
united states
donald trump's ideas aren't just
different
they are dangerously incoherent she's a
world-class
liar just look at her pathetic email
server statement
i believe the person the republicans
have nominated for president
cannot do the job hillary clinton's
message
is old and tired he is temperamentally
unfit she's virtually done nothing right
she's virtually done nothing good
somebody got under his very thin skin
she just talked about trump she does a
speech about what
how unprepared trump is what kind of how
kind of a clown he is
how ridiculous he is and that has become
the driving fuel of her campaign
she does not have the judgment this is
not
someone who should ever have the nuclear
codes
the mindset in each campaign is going to
be to go make the other person
glow in the dark more they're going to
try and irradiate each other
i know these problems can all be fixed
but not by hillary clinton only by me
that is the choice americans face
it is a long way back to arkansas in the
seventies
where hillary clinton began to build her
political persona
in defeat and victory through the
governor's mansion
friends here say the cold and aloof
candidate america sees
is not the real hillary
i was anxious to meet her i mean i i
thought this is going to be someone
really special
and the first minute i saw her
she smiled i smiled she
came into the little headquarters she
said your patty
and i said yes you're hillary we hugged
and we've been
hugging for the last 48 or 9 years
we just liked each other um
i thought she was so authentic and i
thought
um i didn't expect this
raucous laugh this she's
it's i mean when she laughs it's a laugh
i can't relate to the comments that some
people make
about her character i'm kind of
old and life is kind of short and i've
had
your circle become smaller of friends
and family as you get older i'm not
going to
maintain a friendship for my whole life
with someone
who would have character issues or who
or who would
ever be questioned about her
trustworthiness and her honesty
[Music]
from the small town south came the rise
to life as one of america's elite
out of reach maybe out of touch for most
americans
do you think that is something that she
hasn't managed to do to get those
personal qualities across
it's an interesting question and i think
hillary's just beginning to really share
some of the personal side of her life
she's a very
public person with a
real desire for privacy i've known
hillary for decades
and i know her very well and i know her
experience very well there's a real
gallery there of uh yeah al pacino who's
a really good friend
yes and and henry kissinger helped a lot
with the project
i worked on called the four freedoms
park i had the privilege of
finding the clinton's two homes two
houses
i was their real estate broker and
the one question in hillary's mind
always was
is there an appropriate room for my
mother
sometimes we visited houses three times
and at the
end of it if hillary didn't find the
room for her mother to be good enough
the house had to be ruled out she is
a person of family as
i have never experienced in all of my
professional or personal life
i really i really wish my mother could
be
here tonight i wish she could see what a
wonderful mother
chelsea has become and could meet our
beautiful
granddaughter charlotte
and of course i wish she could see her
daughter become
the democratic party's nominee
she was very close to her mother and her
mother and i were very
close to each other it's a it's sad to
me that she's not here to watch
hillary be the first woman nominated
viral party
it's also a little bittersweet i'm sort
of glad she doesn't have to see
some of the brutal things and some of
the
fabricated things that are said about
her daughter
the laws and regulations the death of an
american ambassador three members of a
u.s security team
on the ground her life story is now
fodder for a multi-million dollar
industry in attack ads it seems the more
she shows
the more is thrown back at her
[Music]
it causes great consternation when she's
when she proclaims i will be the first
grandmother in the oval
office i'll be the first woman president
i will be breaking glass
ceilings we've been doing focus groups
with with women who are
either weakly for her undecided or
weakly against her but
not hard partisans and you show footage
of her saying things like that
and they start arguing against her we
don't want to be judged on our gender we
want to be
judged on our the value of our ideas and
our achievements
donald trump likes to say i'm playing
the woman card
and i like to say if fighting for equal
pay
planned parenthood and the ability to
make our own health decisions is playing
the woman card then deal me
in
[Music]
we're the most complex society in the
world
we could have a millions of people
studying us the way
turtles are studied in galapagos and and
i don't think you'd
come up with with too clear an answer i
mean we are an
infinitely complex culture
by some measures it's the most liberal
generation in american history
it's also the most diverse generation in
american history young people
believe that they are race blind and
color blind and gender-blind
but that may only be because they have
yet to
wake up to some of the ways the system
works
there's no way of knowing what it is
that quote
americans expect one of the things in
this election
is to a large extent as much about the
american people
as it is about these candidates my sense
is by the time we get to october
the candidate is able to find some
significant part of their message mix
that's devoted to laying out a positive
and optimistic vision for the future of
the country
is a candidate who's probably going to
have a good shot at winning
travel the country and you hear a lot
about an america divided
and it is no more evident than on who
should be their 45th president
no candidate in history has been so well
known to the american people
it rests with them whether to end her
political
career or hand her the greatest prize of
all
american woman
if she becomes president i will think i
died and went to heaven
she's the best qualified candidate in
probably 50 years
maybe more
i think she's the best person for the
jobs absolutely
i'm hoping i get her autographed today
american voters have good instincts
and what people really want to know is
can you relate to people like them
can they imagine you in the oval office
really there's only one issue and that
is
donald trump is unfit to be the
president of the united states
the ball is kind of rolling down the
hill towards the hillary clinton
election
she is a tough competitor she's
surrounded by a machine
she'll be superbly financed
magnificently staffed
she's personally a directful candidate
but she'll make up for some of that by
the skill and the nastiness of the
people that surround her
it's absolutely a historical milestone i
mean here we've been for more than 200
years and all of our presidents
have been male so she would be the first
whether it's a reason to vote for her
i think that's what we have yet to see
in the general election it will still be
difficult to get there
but i think you'll find in the end that
the women of america will be there for
hillary
[Music]
if we stand together we will rise
together because we are
stronger together let's go and make that
face
to america thank you god
[Music]
american woman